spend the los angeles los angeles county
was a leading agricultural county in the
united states into the 1950s but you
didn't know that grew some of the best
citrus orange trees in the world world
war two in the industry that sprung up
there and making hollywood change los
angeles today it's known for its movies
and they're in freeways you don't find
very many orange trees the other great
example is Silicon Valley when I was a
kid Silicon Valley was called the valley
of heart's delight when you went there
in spring it was full orchards and
flowers when I was in studying soils it
was used as a place where some of the
deepest alluvial soils in the world it
happens to have just the right climate
just the right soils and really clean
water we're growing some of the most
flavorful plums and apricots and in
fruits you can find anywhere in the
world and until the 60s Silicon Valley
was the largest fruit growing in patent
area in the world you can't you be
pressed to find an ordinance of the
valley my point is that we need to
protect those places that are
appropriate for growing food and I don't
think I'm wrong to say there's more of
them are not being made and they're not
easy to create
so it's the Down arrows that would this
way this thing works good so we started
in this little Valley in nineteen eighty
by 1985 I was bored and we began we
moved I took a trip down to this place
down here the tip of the Baja Peninsula
and we found a group of agricultural
community small growers one to two acres
from three and four and they all had the
same problem they didn't have a market
for what they were growing but they were
all great farmers and we've decided to
develop a new business and with a very
clear goal and that goal was to improve
the standard of living the quality of
life for the people living in that
community and that involved into
something bigger a company called or
brand called del Cabo and over the last
30 years has expanded to working in over
10 different communities up and down the
Baja Peninsula and in the last year we
began working in Sonora with a group of
yaki Mayo Native American Indians and
the point of del Cabo was to teach
families how to grow food without all
the chemicals without poisons and it
actually introduced into the things that
there are we growing crops that had a
market in demand in a global marketplace
we were targeting in the beginning
California and that later became the
United States and later
Canada and today you'll find a cobble
products as far away as abu dhabi and
sleep aboard but there's a lot growing
too goes and the growing one healthy
tomato flower oops how did that happen
that's okay and when car first called me
up and asked me I would make the time to
come out here I had in my mind that I
would walk you through the trials and
tribulations of taking a seed planting
it in producing a truckload of cherry
tomatoes but when I got the questions
back I thought we're not going to do
that but we'll talk about a little bit
so it doesn't really matter if you
prepare the soil with shovels like these
women are doing in a farm north of
Shanghai or if you start with a d6 cap
and get a big disk their big round
circles that are sharp that rotate our
pull behind a tractor in drive through a
field whether you you're farming
conventionally or your farming
organically the processes that say the
first thing you have to do is make a
place to plant the seed or trend or
plant the transplants you can't do it
where there's other things growing so
the first thing you have to do is kill
everything is out there prepare the soil
and make the bed so I bet it's
appropriate for growing a plant
on farm in California in farm Mexico we
use John Deere tractors after we run
through with a disks we go through with
a chisel it's a an implement that's
about three feet rips that rips a hole
in the ground on three feet feet sounds
pretty dramatic but the whole reason we
do it is to we're we're trying to open
up the soil so roots can penetrate down
and when you grow a plant when you know
when we walk out and feel you look at
all those clams you look at a tree all
we see is what's growing above the
ground but really the action is below
your feet that's really worth where
everything is happening that's where
there's one handful soil has over seven
billion things living but we we miss
that I don't think about to us so back
to plant in these plants so you get that
your bed going so that one big
difference between the way we're farming
and the way the conventional farm farm
is and how we deal with our weeds so now
we've spent all this energy spent all
this diesel fuel disking field and
getting a ready to plant and then we
don't want weeds to come back or if they
do come back when we planned that we're
going to bring us to battle with them
and that's the biggest difference in
cost going to one of the questions from
one of you between farming organically
and farming conventionally is the cost
of managing the weeds that come up when
you're growing across so in this
operation they were doing it by half in
California and Mexico we do a
combination of things
now if we were farming conventionally
we'd have a shopping list of herbicides
that we could use but we don't do that
so when I first started I didn't know
any better and we just where it went out
and planted the field simply got it
prepped and we irrigate and the first
thing that happened was all these weeds
came up and the weeds were happier than
the plants we planted they grew faster
than the plants we planted and was a
problem so the next time we did it we
watered the field before we planted and
all the weeds came up now we had a
chance to go after the weeds so there's
three tricks one is you can go through
and cultivate the soil half to one inch
deep and that kills all these little
weeds that are coming up again you're
killing things the other is can mount
the propane tank behind the tractor and
you can flame the weeds the flaming is
an old technology that was used 30s or
40s and it's coming back and it's a
really nice way to get rid of weeds
their freshly emerged without disturbing
the soil and the reason you don't want
to serve the soil is when you do the
service or there's more sea weed seeds
that come up and the last technique is
to use a strong vinegar and there's
product now available for ganic growers
is basically vinegar that burns back the
weed seeds and the reason I'm talking
about weeds is only because I want to
make the distinction between organic
growers and conventional growers and
that's a big challenge for the gap
organic guys how to deal with the plants
that you don't want there so we've got
our plant seated or transplanted if
you're growing cherry tomatoes or the
sugar snap peas or great or some kinds
of berries you have to stake them and
you have to tie them up and run string
so every 3-4 feet you put a stake in the
ground
and the reason I'm going through this is
I'm trying to get across you the idea
that there's a lot of work involved in
growing one cherry tomato when you go to
the store buy a little package of a
tomato or a cucumber there's an enormous
effort got into growing that one fruit
it's not trivial it's a lot easier to
write a computer program but you get
paid less for doing it believe me so
along the way this is a this is
photograph of the tip of the Baja this
is taking 1987 and what this young man
is doing is opening up and open up the
hole right here is transient allow water
for this from this French to run down
this row basil that's not what the way
we do it today but to get to the point
of bringing those may of stringing up
those tomatoes or getting the point of
harvesting this is really where you want
to get to there's a lot of steps in
between we've got to bring water to that
plan unless you're in a place where it
rains enough you've got to go through
and deal with the weeds that
periodically come up and you've got to
deal with any other problems that come
up so there's this process that goes on
after seeding and for cherry tomatoes
it's about two to three months of
tending these plants going out there
every day and doing something you know
watering cultivating or dealing with
some kind of problem that you have in
that field
so what are one of the things we did to
mitigate the massive amount of weeds
will come up when we Ferreira gated as
we switched all or growers over to drip
irrigation drip irrigation is a is a
great technology it reduces the amount
of water use and it puts the water where
where the plan needs it so instead of
getting everything wet out here and all
the weeds coming up and then you have to
go through and cultivated it is just
getting it with closes in class so drip
irrigation does two things it puts water
where you want it at limit is it
minimizes the amount of weed you're
having to deal with and it reduces the
amount of water using so that's a little
bit of a background and that's the
really quick story on how to grow the
plant which was going to be the whole
talk I want what I want to do right now
is frame the conversation with three
questions its soil a medium or soil a
habitat does that make sense
this is a place where roots grow or is
the place where things grow are we
manufacturing our food are we nurturing
plants in our insects good or our
insects bad
so it's a little history about the
traditional teradyne or the paradigm of
the industrial agricultural how food is
produced there was a gentleman by name
of justice von Liebig I'm not sure if
that's how you say but he was a he was a
famous teacher he was really well known
as a chemistry teacher and he became
known as the father of fertilizer
industry there was a guy that discovered
that nitrogen is important for plants to
grow and he came up with this idea
living la la minima which was that
plants need a certain amount of food to
grow and above that they don't it
doesn't do any good so if you give him
so much nitrogen if you haven't below a
certain amount of nitrogen they're not
going to grow and above that it's its
excess they don't even the same thing
for these for the other chemicals and
lived and he felt like we could figure
out all the chemicals the plants need to
grow and you can grow plant just
chemicals and his students went on to
promote that idea and in the beginning
there was quite a bit of pushback from
farmers that this doesn't make any sense
you can't do this with chemicals but
slowly but surely this became the
prevalent thinking and when I was in I
went to a school in California cal poly
san luis obispo was an AG school I took
fertilizer class and they taught me
about this kind of stuff and they taught
me that you need 120 to 175 pounds of
nitrogen per acre to grow a tomato and
you needed so many pounds of phosphorus
the grilled tomato and you needed 62 240
pounds of potassium to grow it tomato
and that that's how you did it so I was
taught to go get us do a soil test based
on that soil test you decided how much
fertilizer bike
as an organic grower don't do it too
much different except we don't I don't
think about it as chemistry but we do
the soil test and we do think about
nutrients but we get there in a
different way we'll talk about that a
little bit later so who hasn't read your
cat in the hat gray it's unanimous my
favorite was green eggs and ham but I
bet you didn't know that dr. Zeus work
for Standard Oil it broke some of the
first advertisements for pesticides
didn't know that so this is this is my
favorite part today dr. Seuss he
invented the idea quick Henry the Flint
and flit was a a pesticide that became
this became a household word everybody
knew you had a insect in the house get
the Flint when beasts like this can't
stand one blast how long do you think a
buck and last when someone says quick
Henry the flip I've got one more of
these when beasts like this won't leave
their lairs mere insects better say
their prayers when someone says quick
Henry the Flint say it spray it it's
late and that's been our motto ever
since
so see it's easy it's easy to critique
it's better to understand where this is
coming from so if we look back like
today there's a information revolution
in the 30s and 40s and fifty there was a
chemistry revolution plastics remember
the movie what was the movie would the
graduate go into plastics that's where
your career is it as a farmer if you can
have in my field and I had a feeling
festive with aphids or some kind of spin
awesome kind of were and you showed me
that you sprayed a little dg2 DDT out
there and the worms just drop dead off
the plaques I want it so
in the context of the times this was
real innovation and we didn't understand
the long-term implications a lot of
these materials of nanomaterials Rachel
Carson didn't come along until the 1960s
so in a couple of those papers the
Florida paper on growing tomatoes i
think the other ones a tennessee paper
it went through all the materials you
can use to grow tomato plant malathion
and the Sultan dimethyl diazinon or pyro
five it's a long list of chemicals to
slay it to kill those bugs and for weed
management's the same thing there's
chemicals to kill the plants before
before your seedlings emerge there
pre-emergent herbicides there's
post-emergence er besides there's even
herbicides to de folie ate cotton
gaikwad is use for that
and then of course there's another
shopping list of chemicals to manage
plant diseases so there's two kinds of
plants trees there's foliar plant
diseases and there's soil plant diseases
and they're a real challenge if you've
got a field of green beans and all of a
sudden you you're getting a virus
disease in those green beans or you're
growing onions and you get a soil
disease on those onions what do you do
so so just for a minute pretend you're a
farmer and you've got this crop and
you're about you you're going to lose
the clock and you've borrowed money to
grow it and somebody comes up and says
well now you can you can use red oil and
that will solve your problem so these
chemicals serve their purpose in there
and they've solved in difficult growing
problems for farmers so
we've developed this paradigm the last
in this last 50 years 60 years the
plants depend on chemicals starting with
a famous chemist and that only good but
the only good bug is dead but the idea
really got a big push with dr. Zeus in
some ways that's where we are today but
I like to say that there's an older not
old an older new paradigm it's also
becoming prevalent in today's singing is
being taught in universities and the
reason i would say older and not just
old shows on the screen it's because
many of the ideas and the concepts for
farming that are used by organic growers
we're good we're good stewardship
practices that the Greeks and Romans
knew about feed the idea of feeding the
soil that might be a little different
than that they didn't understand that
the soil was composed of lots of
different organisms that interact with
plants and interact with each other but
feeding the soil is really the essence
of growing a plant in gruene farming
organically remember what I say when we
started look at a plant or a tree
there's more of that more of its
underground than above ground and the
factory the the the mechanism for the
plant getting its nutrients is all
happening below ground yes it's a big
solar collector but all the nutrients it
needs the vitamins if you will that's
all coming from the soil the feeding of
soil is important because a lot is
happening in the soil rotating plants
and that's an old idea and it's part of
the in some pop in some places it's part
of the problem where farmers pay a lot
of money for rents and they feel
compelled to plant the most high value
crop over and over again and they they
don't have the luxury to rotate to a
lesser value crop or to follow a field
follow me rest the field but rotating
the rotating crops changes you're
changing what the depth of roots in the
ground you're changing the way of the
kind of plant the way it's interacting
with it with nutrients in the soil
you're changing the signals that are
being sent out by the plant into the
field so whatever might build up to
attack your plant is now got something
else to to feed on that might not be so
attractive so rotation is important then
this idea of working with insects
instead of thinking of them as your
enemy so this idea of biological control
and one of the classic examples of
biological Pro was in Los Angeles County
there was a a a scale that infected the
orange trees and farmers thought that
they were the entire industry was going
to go down the scale can wipe out the
citrus growing in in Los Angeles County
remember this was a big agricultural
center at the time in USDA said some
entomologist out in the world to try to
find out where this scale came from and
they discovered that scale came from
Australia and they identified some
insects lived on the scale and they ship
them back this was they had sitting back
on boats because there were no planes
time and they brought him back and they
netted some of these branches citrus
trees that were full of these scales and
they released some of the different
species they brought back from Australia
and one of those species that brought
back was a Vidalia Vito you can look up
the story and one of the grauman's came
back sometime later and looked at the
back and saw the bag with the tree was
full of scale and saw the scale had been
well it was God in the end the branch is
full of a daily beetles so he took some
of it l reveals we moved into another
treason another branch was back and the
same thing happened and that initiated
the release of vidalia beetles as a
control for the scale and the problem
went away until something in 60s or 70s
it popped up again in San Joaquin Valley
nobody knew why and they would start
spraying all over again to try to kill
the scale and some extension worker
looked at after that Oh Delia Peter we
solve this problem before and realized
that they had knocked down the daily
beetle because of the insecticide spray
and they were doing and he went out and
found it someplace else and moved it
back and he's orange
they're having the problem so this is
just a great example about insects can
be your friend you can solve problems so
working with working with insects and
then the last point is observing and
managing the whole system and I'll talk
about that a little bit more as we go
forward I want to dive a little bit into
feeding the soil because I think that's
really important cover cropping or
agreement newer crops does everybody
know what that is who doesn't know what
that is raise your head cover crops
agree- across everybody knows what that
is great pretty much they're really
important so so there was a question of
how do you do come crops or even who are
crops and how is it affordable well on
the west coast we do it in the in the
wintertime in the rainy season so it's
when we don't have a crop going and if
it's a perennial crop there's a period
of time we take it out and then we do a
cover crop it's a period of time of
resting this allows the time we're not
going to plant a crop hit the tip of the
Baja in Mexico we do it in the
summertime because it's hot and it's
since the period of time we're not
growing a crop for export different
mixtures of plants a lot of people think
of cover crops as lagoons legumes are
plants that fix nitrogen plant cystic
nitrogen have a symbiotic relationship
with a bacteria lives in the soil or
rhizobium if you pull up a bean plant
that's that's been this fixing nitrogen
then has this bacteria in there in the
roots you'll see little nodules on the
roots if you pop open those nodules and
you break the local New York with your
thumb or your fingernails you'll see
they're sort of red color inside well
that's the bacteria fixing nitrogen from
the air and what fixes nitrogen from the
air it makes that nitrogen available to
the plant
so but we grow cover crop we don't do it
with just the luminance plants we're not
doing it just to fix nitrogen we're
doing it to increase the amount of
organic matter in that field we're doing
it to add organic matter back into the
soil to feed bacteria fungi actinomyces
worms and everything else that's living
there to bring that soil alive because
we've learned with time that there's
there's things in that soil that helped
the plants grow better there's hope
group of bacillus subtilis is a species
of bacteria that's found in soil and
recently a group of researchers
university Delaware found that when the
this particular bacteria signals a plant
to close the stomata when a plant
disease it's feeding on the leaves so
some of these plant diseases they'll
stay a little spore the spore will grow
the sport will then penetrating the
stomata on the leaf but the plant can
close the stomata it's protected it's
somehow there's this interactionist
peculiar interaction between this
bacteria and soiling the roots that
singles the plant and close those two
model so feeding the soil is important
compost people think of compost of the
fertilizer it's not a fertilizer compost
is an inoculant of bacteria when you
make compost that your aerobically
breaking down organic better and you get
this massive amount of fungi and
bacteria so when we use compost I think
of compost as a way of inoculated my
foil with more bacteria
pH the acidity or alkalinity of the soil
is critical to the plants ability to
access the nutrients in the soil so we
we always start by a soil test and when
the first things I look at is pH and a
in the south where the ph is high where
the soil is our alkylene we use sulfur
to lower the pH in the soil here in the
Northeast you could use shells but
commonly lime is used to bring the ph up
because the soils become a sitting in
organic egg we use rock phosphate it
breaks down slowly in the soil and then
down to the tip of the Baja and all the
way up in that desert area we have a big
problem with with nima toils nematodes
and we found that crab Mills presses
meeting notes now why would crab meal
suppress nematodes it turns out that
cram mill has a lot of kite minute so
think of the skin the skin of a shrimp
and the chitin feeds a fungus that
attacks the nematodes so when we use
crab Mills part of our fertility program
we augment the populations of the fungus
that feed on kingdoms and i like to use
seaweed because it has all lots of
different micronutrients and has some
plant hormones in it and then for
growing potatoes growing tomatoes excuse
me we found that in sandy soils where
the potassium cations is a plus 1 cation
easily leeches with rain or irrigation
water it moves down below the root zone
that we needed to supplement the feeding
of the plant for with potassium because
when the fruit forms the plant is
pulling potassium into that fruit to
form the structure and skin of the fruit
it makes firm and if there's not enough
potassium available to that fruit in the
soil matrix at the time the fruit is
sought is still good Fozzy in my
backyard I wouldn't think you wouldn't
need it but because we're shipping it to
you we need that fruit to be firm
because people don't like soft tomatoes
so just a visual of a cover crop it's
about three to four feet high this is in
pescadero it's a mixture of a legume
which is the which is this plant this is
this is a fava bean it's really a bell
beans a little related to follow me we
use oats and veg about 30 30 30 a lot of
guys are working on what's the best
mixture to get the weed suppression to
get you know optimizer organic men or
optimizing increase in nitrogen from
google and in mexico we use corn and
Calpis cowpeas is a legume the corn
gives us massive amounts of organic
matter so and that's US making compost
that's our fertility program and that
replaces buying urea or a 20 20 20
fertilizer or some other chemical
fertilizer I've stand a fertilizer thing
and tell you a story about my herd
conference a soil scientist was working
the Midwest and he was a wave as a grad
student and he kept hearing stories from
the the community that the organic
farmers growth cord didn't have as many
worms in his field as the conventional
farmer I thought that's odd it can't be
true so he went out is he decided to do
is is a graduate work in determine if
this is really true or not so he
identified some organic farms and some
conventional farms and one the one that
I remember strikes me that there was one
when one side of the railroad track was
organic farm another cited railroad
track was a conventional farm and he
went out and counted the worms on the
leaves of the corn plant and sure enough
the organic farm had less worms in the
conventional fire how weird is that so
then he says well why how can this
possibly be there in the same place
they're exposed to the same climate
they're right across the river
attraction each other so we began doing
petiole analysis of the corn plant and
soil analysis and he found that there
was a direct relationship in the in the
ratio of nutrients in the corn plant
leaf and he was able to just by looking
at the razor I'm trying to remember with
sponsors and calcium have to go back and
look at the paper but whatever it was
that he could tell you how many worms he
was fine in a field based on that ratio
and what he concluded was that because
of the way the court the organic farmer
was fertilized in his field for some
reason those corn plants weren't as a
tractor weren't drawing in as many
butterflies or moths or laying the eggs
or making the worms
so a little bit about crop rotations
there's a in the middle of the Baja
Peninsula a place called mula hey and
these there's eight families we're
working with there and they came up with
the rotation all by themselves now I was
surprised when I go there because they
hardly ever have any pest problems they
don't they don't bring anything outside
hardly anything outside the area is
preferred for to add for the fertility
program they were growing they were
raising cows for milk and so they had
alfalfa so when I first showed up there
was mostly alfalfa fields and what they
decided to do was they grow now what
they do is they grow alfalfa for three
years then they planted tomato crop
excuse me then they add some compost and
they planted tomato crop and make the
compost with some of the alfalfa and the
manure from the horse from their cattle
after the tomato crop the next year they
plant peas peas or legume after the peas
they plant garlic one year two years
three years and then they go back in
klamath helping for three years and
they've been doing this for 15 years
pretty sustainable system it's
something's working really well there
because it's hardly any pest pressure
another rotation at the tip of the Baja
where we're not growing as many crops is
cherry tomatoes then a cover crop of
corn and cow peas then we add some
compost when we disc it in grow basil
then we go back and grow this cover crop
in the summer of corn and cow peas add
some compost and cherry tomatoes again
she needs to be worked 25 years
so it's a lot of work can you do on a
commercial scale to feel the cherry
tomatoes you notice that there are
there's these bands of some flour and
corn and sorghum plant and below it or
cilantro that are scattered throughout
this field and we do that specifically
to provide habitat for insects but
things things do go wrong we do have
pests I was just down there two weeks
ago and that's a an army worms for
doctoral and there were hundreds of them
in this one field and I was finding two
species of true blood one was a throw a
name what let the glosses was one and
there was another one was a and healthy
and we two bugs and there something was
drastically wrong so I called in the
expert that gentleman with the insect
net is a retired usda-ars entomologist
and researcher who's been kind enough to
help us with some of our some of our
problems and i'm looking at a little
yellow tube i don't know if you can see
it from the back has sticky paper on it
and the sticky paper insects are flying
by the Wednesday's are the guys who
don't have very much luck and happen to
run in the sticky favor get trapped
there that's the end of them but I get
to counsel so we're we're out there
trying to figure out what's going on why
all of a sudden are all these army worms
out there and why are we having these
two new bugs in these fields are feeding
on the tomatoes so really the point is
we're trying to understand the system
we've seen the system something's out of
whack so managing insects without that
big shopping list of chemicals we saw in
the beginning you know half an hour ago
is not without its not like we don't
have some tools there are bacteria that
in sexy the
them sick and so the one that was the
way ever his story was that there was a
gardener and saw some black lar vie
hanging down from his tomato plants and
they looked like they were dying so he
picked them off the plan he threw him in
his blender and he had some water and
sprayed on the plant and somebody
figured out that that was bacillus
thuringiensis I don't know if the
story's too true but sounds good but
bacillus thuringiensis is a stomach
disease of worms you don't want to get
it because it kills you if you're a worm
it doesn't affect us it's commercially
available and a lot of conventional
growers now are using it because it
doesn't hurt anything else it just hurts
worms that he plants and then repent
they are fungi today available remember
about in the night middle 1980s we began
you working with some Bavaria's a fungus
that make insects sick so there are
tools and biology in in nature that can
be used to control insects that are not
instead of using chemicals that we've
developed in laboratories that nature
hasn't learned to deal with that there
are no enzymes out there in the soil to
break down or in our bodies there's also
this whole universe of insect predators
and insect perito parasitoids it's
really a jungle out there the insects
are trying to eat plants the plants are
trying to defend themselves the insects
they're all making different kinds of
chemicals there's insects trying to eat
insects there's insects leg eggs and
insects it's really well and flowers are
an important part of all this because
the flowers have nectar connectors are
high in sugars so are a lot of the
parasitoids these little wasps while the
Predators they need a sugar source so
flowers are it and you've got to choose
you gotta take the right kind of flowers
because a lot of these critters have big
heads they don't have a long proboscis
that they can like or they they don't
have a big long beak and
like a hummingbird and can't get into a
sage flower so you've got to pick the
right kind of flowers this is a green
stink bug they call it a stink bug
because when you squish it it stinks and
in the entomological feet in the in the
entomology world it's a formerly known
as Mazzara very rula very Loula this
thing showed up tip of the Baja in the
early 1990s it wasn't there before I at
least I have never seen it there before
and we used to harvest cherry tomatoes
into June without any problems and by
middle of March we were starting to see
a lot of discoloration and cherry
tomatoes when you ate them they would be
off flavor but this little this is a
true bug this is as opposed to an untrue
bug so insects bugs or insects but not
all insects are bucks so this is this is
a true bug in the order of Hitler opera
and it has a mouth part that the
piercing mouth part it doesn't too has a
little needle that it sticks in the
plant in fact inside that needle are two
little tubes and out of one tube it
injects into the fruit with the saliva
that breaks down the tissue inside the
fruit and the other tube is like a straw
which it sucks it up but would injects
thats live into the two it makes a fruit
tastes terrible and it discolors it it
got to the point where thirty to fifty
percent of the cherry tomatoes were
ruined and we had to do something about
this green stink bug in the course our
first reaction is where's the flint let
you kill this guy
but it didn't work because he this is
like a little tank out there and
probably the most obnoxious material
that we use is an extract from from a
flower a chrysanthemum flower that's
commercially grown in Tanzania and Kenya
and made into a pesticide let's convert
this sold as pie Gannon it's a lot of
our growers they'd like to use the PI
ganic because kills the bus right but it
didn't do a very good job on this guy so
we went out and tried to understand and
learn about this insect and we found
that there was a little tiny wasp this
thing is really tiny if I means tiny and
it it lays its eggs Italy it lays its
eggs in the eggs of the stinkbug and
it's tuned into the stinkbug it it's
like a guided missile finding it says
so all we had to do was go find this
wasp and bring it over to the tip of the
Baja and we're fortunate to learn that
there was a lab a USDA quarantine lab in
Texas that had been working with this
insect and had been breeding had a
calling of it that was clean clean
meaning there were no hyper parasites on
the synthetic because there are
parasites of parasites and if you're
going to bring a parasite in you don't
want to bring in its parasites right and
this lab had also worked to make sure
that this parasite doesn't parasitize
some of the good guys because there's a
lot of other insects there's a lot of
pollinators it could do some damage so
we were pretty sure that this was clean
insect that it wasn't going to do any
damage to the environment and we had a
friend there a friend of a friend in the
lab who slipped us little was like a
little piece of paper with a bunch of
eggs on it and I put the eggs in my
pocket I went back down to Mexico and we
put him in a glass jar with a with a net
over the top and out of the eggs came
this little critter and we grew these
things out and we got really good at
raising stink bugs because you had to ya
got the stink bugs that lay the eggs to
put the wasp in with the eggs so that it
would lay its eggs inside the exit stink
bug and when we collected hundreds of
thousands of these wasps and began
releasing in the fields in two years
later attack today you can't find the
species in the field yeah you can find
it but it's not the to go back one slide
you can find it in the field but it's
not doing damage to our craft there's a
few of them out there so we successfully
introduced this this loss crystal
lattice masalas solving our problem and
that's what we're doing today with the
with the problems that we sell two weeks
ago what we learned was that these new
insects these new bugs that we found
that
multiplying in our fields and causing
damage to the crop are they came without
passports they came illegally they just
they showed up in somebody's bag they
came on a truck that he wanted an
airplane that came on somebody's fruit
but they came without their host of
predators and parasitoids and so when
they found their tomato field they go
dessert so our job now is to bring the
system back into balance and while we're
doing that we were looking at what out
there is eating them we found that this
this is as Ellison Sasson bug and we
found the assassin bug periodically
attacking some of these critters we
don't want and just just coincidentally
this is a insect lore that's being held
this green thing and we were out there
putting out different kinds of chemicals
to see what chemicals we could introduce
into the fields to tracked more
predators this is Ellis's as president
to increase the predation in the field I
don't know if I kind of doubt that this
was a this was methyl salicylate is what
this is a come from a plant smells like
a flower and just so happens that the
assassin bug with lays eggs on the Lord
and this of course is the classic
beneficial insect right the ladybug
that's how you one my favorite ladybug
story was in was neat in a field near
Ensenada the hills were dry and we got
this migration a fit in this tomato
field and a young man who was in charge
of the field said Larry we got Springs
field all you're going to do I crawling
around the field and I've got every
fifth plant I saw a ladybug said wait
let's wait a couple days and see what
happens three days later there was a
lady but not every plant so behind this
migration of agents came a migration of
ladybugs and a week later neither
ladybug nor a third was was was to be
found so nature nature's has a lot to
teach us a pretty amazing thing species
diversities helps by having different
species in a field you're sending out
different kinds of chemicals you're
confusing insects and you're providing
habitats for different insects
in mixing your crops does the same thing
this is a field of time sunflowers with
cilantro behind it and there's another
herb behind that and then tomatoes those
are rows of tomatoes so that's kind of a
scale that we're doing things in its
commercial scale but we're mixing where
we can we're mixing crops in fields so
bringing this all together our paradigm
is to encourage life there's no reason
we need to grow food in where you can't
take a baby because there's sign this
cross and skull both says don't enter
this field for 36 hours that's that this
doesn't make any sense to grow food
something that we put in our body and
have to use these kinds of poisons it's
understandable why we're using them but
doesn't have to be that way there is
another paradigm and that's encouraging
life in learning from nature feeding the
soil improving the soil structure
encouraging species diversity finding
this insect balance that I was so many
stories i was telling you using this
idea of habitats for insect and
understanding the whole system when
something's out of rat out of out of
whack and gone crazy so I want to just
diverge off to you know sidetrack for a
little bit i thought i would be there
would be a mistake not to include this a
trend today in growing growing
vegetables is protected agriculture
protected agriculture is using
greenhouses and screen houses structures
with fine mesh all around them is they
have their pros in their cons of course
the big one is it modifies the
environment gives you more control of
the space you're growing plant in it
also limits the entry and also the exit
insects doesn't keep them out completely
unless you're really really good but it
limits them so you we have a case right
now where the aphids are getting in and
nothing else that's a problem and we're
you're getting significantly higher
yields being controls the environment a
little bit better 2x or more so just to
give you some numbers out of the open
fields we get between five and six
thousand boxes of cherry tomatoes in the
heck tire which is two point four acres
in a shade house am i running out of
time yep okay in a shade house or in a
greenhouse we can get ten to twelve
thousand boxes an acre so the cons are
high capital cost maintenance and the
susceptibility of storm damage so just
that this idea of protected agriculture
isn't new the Chinese have been doing
this for a long time they were building
earth and structures and they were
covering them with straw mats at night
to prevent the night radiation for going
up when cheap plastics came along they
incorporated a corporated them into what
they were doing you can see the this is
the same matting they used before there
are plastics they're using with the
plastic the whole the heated and this is
what looks like inside very high
population of plants can barely walk
through there and the same thing that
we're doing the little more high-tech
this is a plastic greenhouse these are
peppers high population the blue strips
or to monitor insects the white box
the white box is a box of bumble bees to
pollinate the peppers just to give you a
sense of what this looks like on the
inside these plants are get to be 10
feet hot tall the tomato plants can be
30 feet long it's literally a forest of
plants and these things one of the
strategies is the remove the lower
leaves after harvesting the cucumber's
because we take off those are where that
the disease tends to build up we move
those leaves out of the greenhouses and
it mitigates disease problems and just
another picture of popping the lower
leaves you can just get a sense how many
tomatoes around these plants
how much time do I have
okay I wanted to talk a little bit about
some of the problems these are nematodes
I think these are beautiful pictures of
nematodes and I borrow this from a
researcher at UC Riverside and tone but
the one in the where the arrow is that's
a plant parasitic nematode until by the
stylet that's what it sticks into the
plan to feed if you give you a sense
I'll be I don't know if you can see the
little white thing under the blue arrow
that's how big they are and that's what
they do the plants you're not going to
buy that carrot you see it in the store
so the best thing to do about these
nematodes debride for them and we have a
breeding program that we read our tomato
plants to be resistant to nematodes but
we also breathe for flavor and for yield
is to show you before we start breeding
that's what on your left is whether
tomato plant roots look like and when we
finished our breeding program now we
have tomato plants the root look like
this so breeding is great we've done the
same thing with a leaf disease
alternaria effects they the leaf of the
plant and after a few years we were able
to bring into our mail leaves that
aren't impacted by this disease and
here's what it looks like in the field
and you can see your heart if you're the
grower your heart's going to sing but if
you can have a plant that's resistant
you don't have to do anything so a
disease and especially soil diseases can
be the end of your day and there was a
couple of papers about soil fumigants
methyl bromide and so that's the way
typically soil diseases are dealt with
and nematodes are dealt with with methyl
bromide kills everything but there's
some other tools you can Solarize your
soil which is just covering with plastic
watering it and letting it really hot
crop rotation helps compost helps and
there's this idea of seed mills which
i'm going to try
in 10 minutes and anaerobic soil
disinfection you want to cut it off okay
all right I'm going to show one I wish
it one slide you want to talk about the
seed meals chemistry of seed meal these
are mustard seed meals it turns out that
mustard has glucosinolates in them and
inside the tissue of mustard plants and
in the sea there's an enzyme called my
rosin ace and when you mix that enzyme
with the glucose in lace and add water
you get all these other chemicals and
these chemicals are biocidal at
herbicidal so it opens up the
opportunity to use plants as tools in
farming so